well welcome everybody this is the
Thursday October 24th 2019 session in
our series on edge computing and I'm
Richard - I direct the u.s. Asia
Technology Management Center we're very
happy to produce this series with
support from our member companies we
hope you'll all stay afterward and enjoy
some refreshments outside where the list
of our member companies is displayed and
today we're continuing our discussion of
use cases for edge computing so we
started off with talking about 5g
networks and we talked about AI chip
acceleration then last week really we
had our first use case scenario which
was autonomous vehicles this time for a
very different reason we're going to
talk about edge computing specifically
as a way to deal with privacy issues in
regard to medical data so our speaker is
dr. Thomas close L who is the co-founder
and CEO of Alken which has only been
around since the year 2016 but Alcon
uses machine learning to integrate
biomedical images genomics and clinical
data to discover biomarkers and
mechanisms associated with diseases and
treatment outcomes so the reason here
for edge computing is to keep the
analysis where the data is located so as
to be in compliance with HIPAA
regulations European GDP our regulations
and other things that really have up to
now made it almost impossible to look at
distributed databases with medical data
so doctor close L is former assistant
professor of clinical unco hematology at
the open tileable door in Paris
Thank You Sadie yeah thank you and he
was a research fellow at
the vial Cornell Medical College and he
had led several projects focused on
prediction of resistance to chemotherapy
and beta cell lymphoma so he comes from
the medical side which means that the
artificial intelligence side were people
that he connected with and we'll ask him
to talk about how he got started with
this and what his vision for Alcon is
thanks so much for coming thanks so much
for inviting me everybody very happy to
be here and to discuss with you what I
think and hopefully you will think as
well is the future of medicine and
research I just want to go through a
quite quick presentation to try to make
you understand why today we are still
having troubles to make new drugs coming
into the market we've been on the peak
of new drugs happening in the industry
with immunotherapy which is a drug that
modulates the immune system to treat
cancer with gene therapies which is a
way to probably solve some cancer from a
patent agency has been treated
completely so we have been like to pick
up really really good discoveries but
know everybody know it's gonna be like a
few a big time where no revolutions that
might come in the in the in the patient
world and the reason for that is we
still have a problem of doing medical
research efficient the problem is we
don't really know how to integrate the
new tools we don't know how to have a
good access to medical data and the visa
might be a lot of ways to actually be
more efficient and the way we bring new
innovation on the yearly basis and no
half a century every type for belly to
gives better care and better outcomes
for patients so I just want you to think
with me about what is that a medical
data today and I really believe it's
eternal self question and this is really
complicated because who belong who the
data belongs with so just imagine you
have a woman that is pregnant as she's
in the hospital right she's gonna give a
lot of information to her physician
about her history of pregnancy about her
medical conditions and all the
informations are gonna be you know
written down in an EHR she's gonna get
some kind of imaging hopefully not too
much because she's pregnant and maybe
some genomic tests for her and her kids
the big question first is
all the story we could it electronic
medical records who does it belong to in
the US where you pay for your own data
set where you give a lot of money for
insurances you would say it belongs to
me that's kind of pretty much
straightforward and in France what the
government is paying for everything and
you paying pretty much zero when you go
to a French hospital is you paying not
nothing the data belongs to yourself
it's your body right
also to government that paid for it
because you haven't paid for anything
and actually who knows the answer
nobody so today we are building AI and
access to data on the big question mark
on who the data finally belongs to and
and in France for example just to give
you the set of things we know who data
set a research that I said belongs to
the researchers but an MRI or electronic
health records belonging to a pregnant
woman
we have no idea and this can even go
further
who doesn't know God belongs to so
there's really funny stories in France
recently I'm taking things about of
France but it's the same from the full
Europe you know when you give birth
there is the placenta that is linked to
the baby and the pleasant terror of
woman wants the present attack because
in some it needs such as the Mexican
ethnic you say we do the do lot of
things with it as the traditional people
just more that doesn't apply because it
comes from the body of the mother I was
licking the mother to the baby however a
placenta no one knows who present AB
belongs to in Europe which means there
is a lot of situation naturally
happening whether mother asked to
depress on the back and the doctor is
not look it's mine who do you know
initially like no one knows a place who
placenta belongs to because it's half
the baby have the mother and there is no
legal actually accreditation or the
legal definition of who a placenta
belongs to and you can imagine the
situations where just a mother asking
for her placenta is being denied the
access to our own organ and this is
reality and it's actually real
situations and then like just imagine
you say okay well we just do accept that
medical data belongs to the patient
because this is how it makes sense
especially in countries where it was a
private health care sector that pays for
a where people paste together own data
the big question is can you actually
felt this data online
and just giving one example of a company
called on Genesis that helped develop a
blockchain technologies with a turkey
and a way of being paid to pay to just
put your own EHR data online and just
see if you make any money from it
because there's a lot of buyers for this
type of data sets right what do you
think about the ITU you know it has to
be like waking up well yeah we can do it
maybe we should not do it there is a lot
of companies in the genomic space as
well one called Namira genomics that is
doing the same you just put your ginger
you spit on the tube
so do your genomic testing we as I do a
parsnip profiling it's little markers in
your DNA and then whatever happens is
that you can just complete right a
phenotype data your own characteristics
I like to drink this type of alcohol I
don't drink this at the spot and then
they just don't sell it with the link of
you like I said and you might make money
others actually did it I have a neck
Modi maybe my phenotype is not very
interesting today but you you have ways
to monetize your own data set but I
think we don't belong to you that's
another question and right this is even
worse
of course but you're not always aware
that you that are gonna be sorted so
when you do 23andme you you know they're
gonna keep the data that might be used
for research purposes but it's not
explicitly so that they're gonna sell
the full data sets to AstraZeneca it
happened which makes sense but you know
people that the information is not
really loyal to people today in these
fields
and so the other question is imagine
that on the patient level and if you
want to go to a more upper level which
is the cohort of patients right who
cause of patient belongs to so I'm just
giving you this is a New York Times
article from last year but a very very
famous New York hospitals that I'm not
gonna sign the name as actually given
access exclusive access to the cohort of
patient data at one AI companies saying
okay you can give me a nice little
access to these data sets no one else
will have access we cannot sell it as a
provider to any third party company you
we will have access to this patients and
against it you gotta give us shares in
the company or just money really the
program is the owner of this company was
actually working in this hospital and so
literally there was a big mix-up of
different staff they thought that I
sense were belonging to them which was
never proven and they given exclusive
access to data set and it raises two
questions the first question is can you
give a nice receive access data sets
because financially it means the
hospital is not gonna make any more
money sending it to all the third
players so then I gotta make as much
money as they could with these data sets
and the second question is if you're a
doctor and you believe in research do
you want to have an exclusive grab on
any that I said at all and then the
question is okay imagine we okay to
share data and we okay to sell data then
if you want to do that you need to
analyze the data sites right we also say
they identify data set so today you can
have like switch the names of different
algorithm to change of different keys to
be able to do so
but is it true to death that we can well
analyze data sets and if the answer is
no we can't
what is the consequences the consequence
is that we let us never leave the
hospitals because you can always wait on
to Phi the identity of somebody and this
is actually a true story from last year
as well maybe you heard about it right
there was the story of the girl that get
killer so the garden-gate killer who was
actually from the area he's not here
today actually like being I was he was
searched for 25 years he killed like 20
people or no one knew but there they
have a hair belonging to him they did
not know what to do with this hair and
for a little while
because they didn't have the you know
the amplification of the DNA
technologies to be able to have enough
DNA to have a test but finally they got
a profile of of his DNA with different
snips different markers of his DNA but
then the question is okay we could
profile his DNA but no he's not in our
file he'd look at her file he was 25
years ago didn't even have a file how
can we find him and then he inspects or
actually had a great idea he's gonna
cross this whisper me database of DNA
because when you do 23andme our current
dynamics or ancestry National Geographic
whichever you want
you actually can say that you agree that
some part of your DNA will be shown
pervy database for purpose of research
unfortunately for this killer his cousin
accepted to do the server right so that
just cross his DNA with the big pervy
database and the file name there was his
cousin because it has the same name it
was an Italian name a few members may be
written here but and they say oh my god
this name was one of the policeman's I
was doing the inquiry to find the killer
he was the killer and I got but with his
DNA we cannot actually didn't defy
anything whenever the with genomics and
so today the lesson is whenever there is
genomeics
involved okay in the in the in the data
sets you can always find a way to quite
really don t fight a patient's in
crossing his profile with a pervy
database and if you don't have the
genomics whether this is AI today in the
future in a year or two we'll be able to
predict your dynamic for you with your
CT scan or when you over just a picture
of your face
so just like even if you don't have the
genomics available we'll be able to do
it so the consequences is in the area of
dynamic test we can do it and is it the
question also is is it frequent that
people do have because you need a lot of
people to be able to to have to cross it
with genomics if only like 0.001 percent
of people have a genomic test
yeah I mean the probability of any
somebody family family is low but do you
know did you know that actually 23 and
make all this genomic tests are well
number one on amazon.com last year as a
Christmas gift
like literally I I prefer prescription
and actually so a lot of four percent of
the American population already had a
test four percent right it's very huge
so I with this it's a it's a and it's
probably enough to always find a way to
rate 95 patients when they have genomics
so is genomics is pretty much a threat
to privacy right and and engineering
datasets are way bigger will be both the
fact of radon defying somebody will
judge me the decides it also give a lot
of lag problems if somebody puts you
know a hand on your genome data set
which is what everybody already thinks
about which is like you know credit
refusal interest rates I raise because
DNA contains some free disposition you
know of this disease and the pre-op
disease so you can tell you you gotta be
predisposed to have no cancer it doesn't
mean you gotta have a mo cancer but you
have a certain acute risk to get that so
today like the genomic area just put a
lot of problems ethically and this
gentleman database are or threat to
privacy they have to be different
solutions to be able to get that done
that's the pride of the first CC low on
the data we don't know who the data
belongs to
and we can oh we get we don't know how
to add an image patience really well and
today when you here yeah we shared this
data sense because he was well
anonymized it was day 95 you have to ask
what's the benchmark how do you sure if
I put 50 hackers on you if I put this
great inspector or that fine well we
will find some we will we will find who
you are and if we say that you just have
to question this data broking world that
is the world today data is the new
commodity is the new oil people are
sitting that are like we selling any
anything else and it's your health so
this is the first Scylla the CEO of data
what is the second sido sido I mean when
I hear myself in French accent seven but
yeah you know like it's very hard to to
go through the second thing that is
obviously sided especially in the US but
everywhere else is the health care
system right so the health care system
is extremely fragmented somebody that
needs you know like dialysis when you
have a kidney problem sometimes had to
go to nine different centers one to see
his primary care physician the other one
to go his nephrologist the other one to
have the test done and and do you think
at the end they actually communicate
without them all together no that don't
write the super fragment see there is no
communication communication is of course
the biggest problem in life is the
biggest program with everybody's wife
and husband but it's also the biggest
crime in and so initially like it's it's
very complicated and not only the
communication system doesn't work with
the a a child are siloed in a way the
the of course the euro or your has
because cannot be shared because it's a
competitive advantage right hospitals
that wanna it's making money from it and
don't want to share you EHR so if you H
I cannot be sure how you cure can be
very well organized harmonized it's very
very complicated so there is this
patchwork of care providers in the US
which make your daily care complete
fragmented and another research and the
research is the same the research is
very fragmented people don't share data
right people don't want to the
scientific culture is very very focus
and the competition for funding is huge
because you know this is how you live
when you do research especially medical
research it's it's called publish or die
right this is why you'll say and publish
means having grants usually so it's very
very competitive and
there is a big silo in this research
which makes all this data medical
research and and the health and re and
research and the health care system and
collaborative and fragmented and that we
need explain a lot of why we're not
going forward with more progresses and
white people do because people still not
talking to each other in France is the
same on Europe just to give you an
example friends is exactly the same size
as California right where we are today
California has a few universities or the
big ones we are in one
yeah UCSF Berkeley UCLA but not too many
France has 85 universities I think for
the same territory because they all in
competition that all doing their stuff
sometimes the same thing this is the
world we are in today a siloed world
with rappings are not collaborative and
there is the cloud and so there is all
sort of another silo that is being
created in a way is the cloud so every
big company is today working a big tech
company but even local ones I'm working
on making huge clouds and when I say
early go Paul is like there is a few big
ones where they will play winning the
market and in the healthcare system you
have AWS Google Cloud which have
probably 196 and as your from it
concepts but a lot of people feel ok to
put the data on the cloud first I feel
okay because they think that data are
well under limits but if you think about
it today you probably will not do it
because around the cloud but then I feel
the cloud is secure because the cloud is
very controlled is something that is
held by a lot of people that are
professionals and it's probably true
it's probably the best way today and the
most secure way of living your medical
data is under cloud the program is when
what we call the honeypot effect right
is probably if you're a hacker and you
want to crack something are you going to
try to crack the little servers from
hospital a are going to crack Google
cloud so all the bees are run the same
honey pots which is the cloud today
there is no crack no no leak one day
when you will be happening maybe will
never happen but never never exist it
could be a huge problem so what is the
solution of all these silos and I'm just
today to speak about one of the
solutions but there are many of them
right
it's called federated learning we think
it's a solution to solve the data
program the siloed healthcare problem
and the fragmented care program in a
maybe a more minor way but it's one of
the solution we want to develop in our
company
okay so what is the idea of a written
learning technologies and federated
learning is just a new way 12 access to
data with a vision division it means I'm
a doctor I think my patient should not
share the data out I think I don't want
that ask my patient to be out of the
hospitals and I want people to
collaborate right so the technology just
solve that it means like before what was
happening the standard approach is data
are put in a server in a cloud
aggregated together and analyzed on the
web after aggregation the idea of
federated learning is you don't need to
aggregate data sets it just like the
models will be trained locally and then
you will travel
but the data stays on prima is within
the firewalls so the data will never
leave the hospitals and it's not an
issue for for for data healthcare data
is true for your mobile phone right your
mobile phone today the data uploaded on
the cloud and be analyzed with different
analytics tools on the cloud and an
aggregate accession but in the future
you will have your little ai models or
your little analytics tools that will
just go on your mobile phone and trained
locally so you doesn't if don't need to
live the the mobile phone and Google is
doing for it an amazing way of trying to
develop this technology for digital
solutions which also give a lot of that
for the C data sets they also serve as a
try to think about the way we access
data in the future in a safe and
privacy-preserving way as well so the
first thing about filete learning it is
this right it's privacy preserving and
you can the way you can have this
algorithm is being trained on Hospital a
then you can go come back being trained
on hospitals be the data never leaves
the hospitals and at the end you can
collaborate with a lot of people because
the algorithm can travel and you can
train your algorithm in a little abcdefg
and capture the agility of patients
today a lot of AI solutions are built on
the specific country and then when you
try to use its right it's not robust
it's not global you cannot be globalized
because it was trained on a specific
population and it works very well on a
specific population but today the world
we will is just like we all want to have
like models that works on any type of
patient whatever that background is a
genomic background is whatever the type
of prescriptions are gonna have you also
want to capture hoped Toto's prescribe
drugs differently
because the same drug he prescribed
completely differently at different
doses in Stanford and UCLA the same drug
right so you want to be able to train
your model it Stanford and UCLA and the
way to see like how that how research
can be globalized is true fidelity
learning in waking a way to distance
relies the way you train your
intelligence and at the end what does
this collective intelligence realize
intelligence results in the collective
intelligence right because you can train
things with multiple people in the same
area and then the only way when you
think about this being privacy
preserving and collaborating with many
players you need to think about also how
do you go and check that everybody put
the right data in and the solution is
blockchain right so nothing there is
anything with abduction today but we're
not making in the exception if you want
to build a model with different
countries different centers with shangay
Paris Tokyo and Stanford you also need
to know who put which data in the system
and the blockchain we'll just a note if
we will through different Ledger's you
know rejoice different markers that just
bill written in the kind of a book where
you can never take the pages out who put
which data in this model so the ledger
and the blockchain is a complementary
solution of trust ability that is really
important in the nav element when you
want train things with different
hospitals and trailers and then at the
end what is the two things that that are
possible with federated learning we
think the models are going to be better
generalized you can meet with or
generalize to different populations
because it was trained on different
populations as well you can use one
hospital as a validation test you know
AI is all about how you validate your
tests right training a model can be easy
you can use different repeatable sense
but you always need independent
validation data sets to be able to see
if your model is real and this is just
the way you can have different hospitals
can play the role of a validation that
has a tool so you can multiply at the
infinite and as much as we want the
possibility of having external
validation of results and the second
things is even even things going to be
more accurate as models because it's
going to capture so much easier Det that
whatever data you will put in it it
won't affect the prediction and the
capabilities of making a good AI model
so at the end the future of fidelity
learning it's not only collaboration and
privacy-preserving
it's also being generalizable and just
having better more accurate than
and aggregated data sets so we really
see the future with this and it's not
only true for healthcare data it's true
of course for defense that are right you
can have access to different Hospital
imagine there is a an attack a
biological attack it's a real situation
where where people's people try to use
fidelity learning for you would have
access to all the hospitals data sets of
whatever backdrop is around in all the
world simultaneously and you would be
able to build simultaneously a model
with everything in the world so this is
also a way to see how difference can can
use this technology in the future and
there is also other benefits you you can
speak so that may be less possibilities
of cyber attack because you don't have a
cloud you have local clouds or local
servers when you train your models and
you have multiple so if one is being act
well it's not as bad as they're all
we're right you can simplify all the
political silos because of course
everybody has political complexity about
like trying to collaborate together here
you can just train the algorithm you
don't need to have years of negotiation
with every hospitals trying to like
break the why we're not working together
and I'm sure in the Stanford is not
working with UCLA that is not working
with Berkeley whatsoever in any case and
then the trust ability interpret ability
that I told you about to really
understand who put which data points is
the model so this is just come to who we
are and we are so we want to make this
very meaty learning happen to create the
best ecosystem for people to develop
better drug we want to build the best
platform of drug development in the
world and we are vicious to do that and
our ambition comes from the firm from
three years ago where I was I was a
restaurant professor I was treating him
for my patients and I was trying to
build a research program on how you can
predict resistance to chemotherapy and I
was in Cornell and I was in Paris I was
a plain girl I was in Paris treating
treating patients and I didn't find a
way to make Cornell and Paris
collaborate and it's like what and it
was impossible and also was using by
informatics which was not very useful
and this is why I discovered the world
of AI and I was completely new to me
through my co-founder Jill who added she
who is a Stanford alumni we have a few
of them and who has a postdoc doing his
postdoc here and who's starting to
publish paper about how a I can improve
prediction of respond to treatments or
survival using any type of medical data
so we created like we are we work
three years ago we are around 90 people
and we are mostly French as a company
philosophically but but but legally we
were American and we I got like good
funding so different venture venture
France including Google venture and I
have the chance to get my investor here
today a demand and fidelity
a Frank with a biotech front so we
really have funds that understood the
intersection of healthcare and tech
which is pretty rare and then yeah we
really have top cowgirl talents for the
know the ones we Windhoek a girl we have
number one and two in France okay girl
masters that we we partner with multiple
hospitals but and we have an amazing
federated learning team so federated
learning team you need the right people
right because federated learning as you
understand it's a hospital's building
something here hospitals building
something there it's an orchestra so
it's really like an orchestra master and
I'm a very same English but so the
orchestra master is kami and and Metsu
who are building all our infrastructure
to have algorithms travels in every
hospitals and and being able to find if
use a program so just imagine failure
with a imagine networks is that it's
like a tunnel we are building a tunnel
between all the hospitals we are
partnering with they also building the
little is that we that is the the
infrastructure and then Eric is building
the federated learning algorithm the
little trucks they gonna go into to
collect on informations and we also
building the doors is there is a problem
that we can go out of the cistern all
right in the future so it's a bigger
it's an effort that involve people that
are really good engineering developing
and also data scientist know by
traceability cryptography and machine
learning so it's a big it's a big effort
and the three people are leading
different teams in the company and this
is really like what we want to do what
we want to achieve today is being able
to partner with a hospital a getting
access to that time but the data will
never leave the hospitals access to any
type of data from pathology to medical
imaging and building of models never
compute in the computer of the the
people there it will travel to a
hospital be being trained a hospital be
as well you can see the birds are coming
stronger and stronger and bigger and
bigger and at the end
any player that can be a family distri
or anybody else that want to have access
to a better drug and to all these models
will be able to use these models built
on this loop of partners to improve the
weather building drugs and this in the
privacy preserving way with models now
were trained in many hospitals capturing
the etiology of many patients and this
is our mission we think that this will
help making drug return developments
better and today as you know just to
give you a very quick context the drug
R&D is this room is low ten years to
develop a drug sometimes less and one
person of chance to be able to do so
it's extremely extremely long and very
risky as you know because it's a little
complicated to build drive the chemical
part is extremely long six years and the
return on investment is expression is
exponentially decreasing so we need more
approach that a driven clinical trials
are built on patients that are you have
a lot of real-world data that can be
transformed into great at visual
intelligence let's use artificial
intelligence models built on patient
data to improve these processes to help
drug development being more efficient
and will bring more drug to the market
in a better way which means targeting
the better population with better
biomarkers and with predicting the
toxicity for hitting the effects
changing the way you've developed drugs
tomorrow so this is what we do and the
way we do this we have three layers in
the company the first one is just the
platform and the data we are building
this decentralized data network and we
are trying to build it with the 100
largest academic research hospitals in
the world so we really want to build
these AI models with the best minds in
medicine which means it's usually like
physician scientist MD PhDs that have
patient cohorts and questions and
they'll K to collaborate with other
people all over the globe and we're
gonna solve a question with all this
network and build the models that will
be helpful for the drugs for example can
we predict response to immunotherapy in
non-small-cell lung cancer with the best
key opinion leaders today and that will
be the one that use the drug into
tomorrow and this is our decentralized
data network with the best academic
research hospitals and this is really
what we're targeting we're not targeting
community clinics we're not targeting
the small ones we want to target the
research questions because sometimes you
know finding the questions is really
hard there's something you always hear
in research and medicine which is Kadesh
correlation is not because
it's not closed but something that is
even more true is if I need the right
questions for AI is extremely hard and I
just need one example of question tell I
will tell you today okay you have all
the tools you want in the world with AI
and all the money and try to help us
treat a brain tumor okay and what is the
right question and you have one question
that you can solve with all your a eye
tools and all the money in the world
what is the question you're going to
take so just to give you one example
brain tumors and never shrink so today
people trade brain tumor but it doesn't
really shrink so you don't really know
issue treatment effect effective or not
so this is really hard to be and so
there is only one clinical trial that
has been done on bread she was always
effective because as you cannot assess
the response to your chemotherapy you
never know if the patient responds and
nuts you have to wait that is clinically
worse or better you can really do a
clinical trial only one trial positive
or the fam'ly
are about joining the brain tumor world
because economies are not really good
for the tumor it's impossible to make a
clinical trial and people are still
dying of it's more than before so the
question is you have all your AI tools
when you what is the models you want to
built what is the algorithm you wanna
build so if you find it the way the
probably the right question is can we
predict with an MRI of the brain if
somebody's got a response a year after I
became a daddy can we buy us can we
build a surrogate marker to that and
find is this question and engaging a
food community around one question that
you think is critical it's not that easy
so this is why it's very important to
build this with the best opinion leaders
finding the right questions to solve
with AI which is the opposite of you
know big data approach where you're just
going to find out supervised things in
in the data sense here it's very
important for us the second thing is the
models we transform these data sets into
models of prediction can we predict the
future can we predict response to
therapies can we predict survival so
last month we had a paper in Nature
Medicine we were able to predict
survival of patients in mesothelioma
which is a type of lung cancer with
biopsies before treatments so with the
image of a biopsy before treatments we
could predict how many months people are
gonna be gonna live and we could also
tell why they're working well is the
biomarkers that could explain that so we
don't try to build models just to
predict things we try to understand what
is the underlying biology and to do that
we completely integrates system biology
and medicine into everything we do
because today we need to open the black
box
you need to understand the story people
survive you can predict that you predict
the I made the prediction happen and why
the prediction works what is the
underlying biology is extremely
important because you want to go through
a motors of predict shot to a new
breakthrough and a new medical discovery
and others very important so you need to
integrate a lot of talents in principle
we have a lot of physicians in the
company I like myself I try to
understand what is the real biology
behind everything and then the third
thing is just transforming this models
and platform to really help people that
want to do better drugs to their farmer
but in the future tech companies or
whoever to help them finding user groups
of patients and in new better processes
to develop the drugs and building better
drugs so this is the data Metro so we're
trying to trying to build is really
unique in the way it's with the best
care where's the best key opinion
leaders and the best academic research
hospitals today in Europe and and the
east of the US but in the in tomorrow in
the full world and we we did try to have
access to any type of data because we
want to connect data together the future
of medicine is not working on the
vertical of AI because if you work if
you have a company that only do regular
gene AI you're gonna be able to predict
the radiology tomorrow CT scan will not
happen Amir I will have disappear
- if you do on the astrology and
pathology tomorrow cancer won't be
defined by astrology pattern but by
genomic right and you want to be able to
connect all the data together and you
don't want to have any dependency on one
type of data and you also want to have
multi modality approach to be able to
understand was the biomarkers everywhere
so we are working with any type of data
and we have a team that is dedicated to
every type of data and this is what we
do and we also have like for the fruit
we have the first team in the world to
have live experiments of hospitals
collaborating together from melanoma and
breast cancer and we have big questions
and we have hospital that agreed to
share the intelligence to try to answer
who is resistance to treatments in in
cancer and if you think about cancer is
something that is always belief a nice
just to show you how we are bad in the
other studying of the disease and how I
can help think about the names of cancer
the word cancer there is one cancer that
is called triple negative breast cancer
is there was cancer it means it's not
negative three times but what is it
there is another one it's called
non-small cell lung cancers one of the
words we just know it's not
more cell there's no idea what is and
actually we don't even know how many
subgroups of patient there are and be
able to predict will help finding new
subgroups of patients that will define
how you redefine and reclassify the
disease so prediction with AI is not
only a new mean to to be researched so a
way to discover new sub expressions and
discoveries so how we do this we really
we equip our data network with servers
our local cloud we put our platform on
the servers and then the researchers can
just upload own data set I usually
curated circulated by them and each is
the best kept in the leaders in the
field to be able to start training an
algorithm automatically and if they want
to share through a larger community and
this is yet the the high-impact models
I've been talking about so today at the
end we're trying to build the lattice
library of models in the world that can
be applied to medical research like
traditional response to different
therapies in different cancer prediction
of cardiovascular risk prediction of
toxicity for immunotherapy because every
new discovery in medicine always come
with a certain degree of toxicity right
and you want to be able to predict that
and it's not only amazing for research
and for discoveries but it's also
amazing because it can help the farmer
to develop better tools and so our our
technical platform looks like this today
it's really like a platform that is a
big software stack that is trained on
our loop of partners and then literally
like connect to different type of tools
the first one is a federated learning
tools at a low people and trust ability
tool that a low people to connect to a
loop of partners our loop order or now
and the other one is a tool that really
enables people to build their own
machine learning models themselves so
it's a tool called
auto machine learning tools if you have
a question you got the model you don't
need to know anything about machine
learning and you can make your model
yourself and this is important to scale
because you want to be able to scale the
loop of partners in the in the future
you very important for you to is very
important for us to be able to have this
medical researcher doing their own AI
models and this is about what is the
vision of AI from medical researcher I
don't think I think the AI won't
accelerate I mean it will accelerate a
lot of processes in radiology everywhere
but for me the biggest impacts of AI
tomorrow for doctors
it will be augmentation right we owe
please augmentation versus acceleration
and augmentation is just how can you
make new things can you predict a
survival of the patients with a CT scan
can you predict if it's gonna it's gonna
be of a different group and should have
a different treatment can you predict
toxicity and this is what it's exciting
right it doesn't replace anybody just
give you more superpowers and and really
I think augmentation is about everything
and this is the future and if you want a
doctor and you want to use AI you don't
need to understand what is that your
network you don't need to understand
what is the exact boost whatever what
you need to understand is how you teach
the Machine the machine is like a kid I
need to educate if you need to show in
different pictures that could be
outliers diversify and so the future of
AI for medical research is and
authorities having researchers and
doctors becoming machine teachers they
will teach the Machine and the
possibilities and capabilities will be
augmented through that and this is a
tool of augmentation the first tool that
we put in the hands of a researcher to
be able to do that and at the end we
have these two products at train on our
loop of partners to be able to get
access always privacy-preserving to the
right data sets and so now I'm just
going to deep dive a little bit further
in what's really the the things that
make me come here today is our federated
learning technology and so this is
something that I'm not an engineer so
but that service video x3 stack we our
technologies one stack with three
different components that is very
important and that really is the way to
build and what I want to show you is not
the solutions is the complexity and why
it's extremely hard to build federated
learning for medicine the first reason
is you need three stacks I will tell you
why the second reason is if you want to
build federated learning it's not the
same if you know twin and logarithm on
different type of data because if you're
not if you're not build an algorithm
with different sensors on radiology
everybody will have a different device
one will be cement when will be the GE
has care what the other one will be and
you need to be able to harmonize this so
this is extremely complex but it's a
simple it's a different automatic for
pathology this and that's a second
problem and the third problem no this is
the two main program so we have built
our first tool is our connects to the
data tool and there is speak upon us the
for the first one is the infrastructure
the tunnel I was telling you about right
the second one is the
the strategies is how you want a little
truck a little SL model to go in the
tunnel do you want to go them very fast
you want them to stop at every hospitals
to be trained for an hour for two hours
do you want to be that train twice into
some centers you have different ideas
you can train things in a different way
do you want to cut this data set in
twice and the truck will come back so
just just a way to imagine a network
right and the second one is that it's
just the network which is the the what's
the matter what's the matter all of the
of the Tuda would it be so it's very
complicated because you have different
ways of doing things and no one knows
the solution because it's a new
technology and you need to be able to
iterate things in a very very rapidly
way and so it's really described here so
the infrastructure will be open source
because the infrastructure is really
whole you get access to the data and I
told you that was a ledger technology a
blockchain technology and so you need to
be a blockchain by definition has to be
open source and so we are building a new
tools that is going to be open to us
tomorrow
that is called subscribe which is the
first ml for machine learning framework
that really enables federated learning
to be a shift into the framework right
it means is the tunnel and is the first
donor that is big enough so the
federated learning trucks can come in
the tunnel right because before all the
tunnels are trying to be built are too
smart where's this big fluid learning
coming and traveling so it's just in the
virulence where you can ship some
parameter learning algorithm in the
future and that can be traced about and
and and and secure the second thing is
the back-end infrastructure that I told
you the FM networks again that is a
software just dedicated only to failure
with learning and the third one is
virtually the algorithms themselves and
you have one from pathology what for
radiology went for mercy images and
their different performances that you
can ship so there is really three
different components to be able to do
and the first one has to be open source
and so this is substrate so the the the
the framework is the infrastructure
that'll be open source the first layer
looks like this it completely is the
terminal is enough agnostic of any type
of data you wanna protocol work with
federal to learning algorithm on any
type of algorithm but what'll always
brings is the privacy and accessibility
and it's just the way to have a little
turn at the tunnel the little like way
to communicate to have different sensors
communicating with different type of
that
sets different type of algorithm and
different type of strategies strategies
is just a way to have your algorithm
live within a different certain
framework so this is a very new and we
really hope like we think it's gonna be
very exciting to ship our fidelity
learning algorithm so then we have this
turn already
ephra we want to ship for every learning
algorithm to try to see on breast cancer
if an algorithm has been trained on one
two three four hospitals will be more
accurate and more generalizable that one
that we would have built if we had
aggregated the data sets and so there is
really two configuration in federated
learning that possible but it's just a
way to open your mind about it because
it's all you just had your algorithm
traveling from point A to point B to
Point C but there is no a centralized
node central node the other one is to
have a central node that is
orchestrating everything so the model is
being trained on data a so on the data
set of lung cancer here yeah it's coming
back another data set and everything is
just centralized into one model
dispatchers can dispatch its Earth's
right
and so we favor of this and it's we but
today no one knows which one of the
which one of the technologies will give
better results and we need to be able to
test both so it's really two ways of
thing federated learning but the prime
is when we are so it's not a problem but
this is we you want a model dispatcher
you want a song for load all you want
everything to be fully automatic the
program is when it's fully automatic and
you don't have some short load that
needs to be a certain degree of
confidence in the people that are in the
network right because you need to know
that if you cannot put really high
quality data sets he's not going to put
very poor quality data sets and very
different than the sets from whatever
you need you need certain degree of
currents right here you just need to
trust him the hotel dispatcher and at
the end in AI and medicine everything is
about trust what is the trust the the
hospitals give it give you what is the
stress you have it in particular digits
you are building today and then to just
to show you the capacity but do you need
to understand this this is a strategy so
how we are building the model are we
building the model in a row on the three
centers and we cannot train the model on
the three centers in parallel
in series and we gonna train the model
on one part of each data sets and see
what it gives are we gonna train the
system is a thousand of strategies it's
extremely complex and here it's our
federated learning mesh technical
science team that is trying to just
develop all the possible strategies to
be able to have the algorithm run and
there's lots of them and all need to be
shipped into this backyard into this
infrastructure before you can actually
see the results so you need to be able
to build the infrastructure you need to
be able to write algorithms and then
which strategy will be the right one to
a federated learning works and then to
finish I just have two sides more there
is all the challenges that are very
important so the trust is probably the
biggest challenge but it's the biggest
challenge in the AI in medicine and I
think with auction this is something
we've really being able to build is the
stress with hospitals because how we
could get that many hospitals in in a
quick time it's just like that trust us
because I know we're not gonna take the
data out and we're not going to make
anything else that are the hospital
trusts as the patient trust us and the
doctors trust our so it's very important
so then there is all the problematics to
be solved the first one is the workflows
is like whenever you enter data sets
into into the into the server this would
be is with a certain type of data
anonymized in certain way because you
need to be able to normalize things at
the end so how do we actually people
work together and if your data scientist
you want to use the the the federated
learning just algorithm and not the
front end you need you were to code in a
certain way so just having like
directions for all the centers in the
loop to say this is how we gonna do
stuff right do we agree or not and if we
have cloud it would be this cloud here
this servers if in certain degree of
agreement between the people still at
limits to the model but it's still
important where people it's only you
don't need to have a big political
signature between all the sensors we
need to agree on how you do that the
second one is a bit the same is the
device program the device program is the
microscope when you do pathology if
there is a picture of the slides of the
biopsy with different microscope it
doesn't look the same different view the
luminosity different color at the CT
scan are from different brands the MRI
have different acquisition time
different sequences so this is always
like normalization problem and
programs that are extremely important
and the thing is you don't see the data
right so nothing you can go and say hey
don't be because I'm going to normalize
data for you because the idea of
federated learning is being able to
train things without ever seeing the
datasets right yourself I mean the model
does so you cannot like actually go with
your hands and change the way things
that's been cleared up the third one is
the orchestration is really how you want
to train the strategies that I've been
showing it before the recession and the
last one is the Delta D ckhead and
security and the idea is whenever a
model has been built at the end you have
a federated model you have you don't
want to know no way to know who has put
which data so you have the block Shana
the deflection will will help you to
know which put who Center which Center
puts data at one certain point of time
but you also need if you have all the
way to be notified that a center like if
you see that for example one Center
loves Christ so more than another one
with your thing you might think it's a
French Center right and so all the way
you can actually add access back to
certain trends really make important and
also like you want to see like if you
build a federated model and to make a
prediction of a response to therapy and
one Center has no effect on the
prediction you might think something has
been wrong right that I have leaked so
something is wrong so you need to be
able to control your we're not like this
and this is just to show that so this is
the workflows finding the right
container the right the white workflow
the right cloud system to be able to
sell your algorithm in the quite
normalized and urbanized way that's very
important so people are going to debug
the things it's one of the first
challenge the second way is the device
you want some things that is device
agnostic right you want a model that
will work on any type of CT scan or any
type of MRI brand in the world and
that's a big challenge and at the end
fidelity learning will be so strong that
you can put whatever you want in the
model whatever if even if like I don't
know like some zoom come with a new CT
scan you won't affect the model because
the model is so device agnostic that
whatever you do and this really
corresponds to the reality right if you
have a nail model say okay but my MA
model does not work on your Philips
machine I'm sorry your patient have to
go to a different hospital to have our
models being trained on right it's just
not the world the world kind of
functions that way so it needs to be
device agnostic
and it's a very big challenge
the second one is what I told you is
data normalization and organization a
very very big challenge and you see the
certain degrees of bootstrapping from
public data set and hypothesis because
you don't know you cannot see the data
set so it's very important to to see to
have to see it so that that no matter is
the same way if each of the center
actually participates in the prediction
right if there is one as I told you that
doesn't have any effect it means that
probably the normalization problem or a
way that I wear where I'm Eliza and the
final thing is I decide you the data
leak head and security whatever the
trend of the the population is you
always want a flat thing at the end
where you will never be able to know
with a different trend of prediction who
was the the population that answer
certain type of data sets so that's it
and and we need so to finish as two
sides more is is it's real so we have
shown you different examples I've shown
you how data says the data is siloed I
show you how healthcare is siloed I'll
show you a way to get out of it with
disparity learning technologies with as
you understood is complicated and have
to be trained and has to be agnostic and
different type of things normalized but
and no we it's really well so we have
different projects that are coming to
test the efficiency of our system and
there is two projects like the prom the
first one is the product is false it's
called health chain on it so you it's a
French project and with the European
grant and the idea is having four
hospitals sharing a different algorithm
on breast cancer and melanoma so it's
the first time in the world
we're like actually four hospitals that
don't know each other with different
population are sharing intelligence on
this to two very bad disease the second
one is called a melody it's extremely
exciting so middle is a project a
European projects that include earth as
an Orchestrator and also ten large
Pharma to share intelligence on the
molecular libraries and I don't know if
you know attack or Big Pharma's the
biggest assets the treasure that sitting
on is the molecular libraries right
molecular libraries is all the molecules
and the chemical properties and no
pharma has ever shared that because it's
something they want to keep and to
desert trust this technology enough to
say let's collaborate all these huge big
companies to collaborate in sharing
federated models to be able to
predicts the binding of molecules to
different targets and and so being
orchestrating this we will have the
results in three years and it really
covers all the three layers the
infrastructure the network and and the
the models and to be able to improve the
way drug discovery is done today and
imagine the level of trust you need from
this large Rama to be able to give you
access to the biggest asset which is the
molecular libraries and the last thing
we we've been trying to do today is
actually trying to also empower some
other with with federated learning and
NVIDIA is competitive building like GPUs
and we are launching a program with
King's College in London and NVIDIA to
be able to actually like build federated
learning with different sensors on the
on the consumer and the way we will add
our federated learning framework in
style
is within the nvidia gpus so whenever
people dies as GPUs GPUs you know it's
cards to to to to to make your machine
learning calculation on servers and we
will have everything in start so we have
an automatic way of being in start with
the hospitals with the agreements and
being able to like deploy hand in hand
with this GPU technology our federated
learning technology so that's it III
hope never sees cocoa agency nothing you
just like to have a look at our website
and our vision and at least you know
when you wonder what is the vision of a
company you speak about 23andme what is
the vision of 23andme on data sets I'm
not sure but it's amazing there is also
great vision position is making amazing
progress I'm trying to make prediction
of phenotypes with biology so making
other things I don't think like the way
like we our vision is we want to build a
collaborative environment for better
drug development and we do believe that
having a sexual access and collaborative
access to data will be part of the
future thank you thank you
so Tomas please bear with me a minute
would you go back to about page 40 or 41
the many sub straw configurations the
two configurations yes one so because
this is kind of a different way of
dealing with data than the typical big
data analytics yeah yes
seeing in typical big data analytics
what happens is you will have some
program inside a data center that will
call for data from a whole bunch of
different places where data is stored
the data will be copied into the data
center and then it will be analyzed
there again a few and so it's the
copying of data that's really a problem
for this medical kind of data it's a
shitty because it's inside because there
won't be weatherized
right nobody knows who owns that nobody
knows what the security is but what
you're doing is basically you're taking
the algorithm and sending it out in this
one from a central location to data
where it can be trained on that data set
and you'll learn something about the
problem about the model and so the
updated model goes back to in this case
the central location mm-hm and then you
would take it to another place and it
gets even more accurate yet named
another list but it's the model that's
actually the mother whether it's it's a
replacement of the data broking they
sent by a model broking right everythi
yeah so coming from a medical background
so tell me how did you start this up how
did you meet the people in computer
science who were trying to use this
federated learning approach but it's
it's really a question of vision and I'm
not kidding I was like I was III I have
a problem I think I was bioinformatics
doesn't fit really well to the
problematics of prediction in medicine
because you know paid for my thesis is
mostly in there and I made the other way
is using images to do so and to be able
to predict things so first again with
this parametric surfaces they need to be
new tools and I read about AI and I met
my co-founder that was the same trying
to replace biostatistics you know in 26
in talking about federal we were
starting to 2015 because we went here
before yeah yeah I think I was talking
to 2t and then we were like most of our
revision we say but we don't want to do
that I broke with them it's we
understood we needed a way to have
access to original data sets and we did
not want to have access to permeated
ourselves like a lot of AI companies are
training the motors on public assets
right and even on the markets a lot of
solutions when you ask which other sets
did you train your model on think oh
it's publicly available and when you
look at it as huge gaps in it right we
wanted to control our access to data and
the way and we were like we don't think
like we both knew that we need to find a
new way to control the access to the
power in the river is that you know how
this data was collected of course you
know exactly what the characteristics of
the data are even though you can't see
the day you get see today so you can
control for accuracy a lot better by
using the data as it yes guidance about
how you actually saw it could be in this
loop the different hospitals that have
their data
do they have to format the data in a
particular way they do it they still do
I mean we I mean with the data I mean
like formatting is like usually like for
example for medical imaging it's pretty
standard right yeah and they still have
a bit of guidelines about how you should
interpret is very simple but at the end
we don't we like changing your data so
if there is new sequences will still be
able to be agnostic from the device
agnostic you device agnostic yeah like
from different models but just the way
it needs to be assembled in a way I mean
we try a small but he needs to be able
to capture the mistakes but it's okay
the usual kind XF like so when you go to
a hospital and you offer this to people
what are the big things of resistance
what's hard about selling this idea to a
hospital you could have fine with that
first not everybody is not fine with
buying data sets that are animation it's
very simple or its efficient there's
many players around so the first
resistance die guys okay with the
successful earning a bit why not I think
like today it's shifting because there's
been like this countdown you know in New
York it's been like this NHS tower it's
been different stories and the amount of
people it's changing but slowly and I
think in the future people will
understand that it's just data not
moving from hospitals it's just a very
simple way to do things
and you don't think about DJs and you
don't think about security and I think
that I think but is there more pressure
on the original developer of a model
typically an AI model will get what
eighty or ninety percent what you think
is really going on but then you leave
the rest for the data to kind of tell
you and yeah go through the training set
of the data then it does become more
accurate you don't have to specify
everything in the model up front no
known object but but yet this is does
this system put more pressure on the
original model formulation no I mean he
doesn't it depends which models on which
type of data because it's very very data
dependent and I don't think it really
puts more pressure on the the pressure
is on their infrastructure and you're
pregnant
okay we need to be very stable and to
the existing me like do you need to be
sure to show that no leakage can happen
whatsoever the first ability is very
important to exactly wet and if you make
a publications you need to know exactly
who did what
everything is complicated in the setting
right but the future is we I don't see
five hospitals I think training every
model on 4050 hospitals with different
relations okay and so and these two
projects that you mentioned at the end
can you go back to that slide immunity
you had the two big projects the melody
project yeah okay so how far along are
these now when did they start
what's so this is this is gonna be
fairly published in march okay so
hopefully even before and we will see
what philippine learning in real life is
given as a result and it was very
exciting and this is gonna be three
years okay oh you gotta take a lot of
time because here yeah so it's three
three years ahead because it's all the
infrastructure being able to a college
with all their IT infrastructure
building the tunnel and then having the
right fileted learning models for for
molecular bending so kind of a nosy
question the companies raised about
thirty million dollars you've got this
ten million euro project here but you've
got you know 80 to 100 people in the
company so
this is not a very long runway never
this is like so this this goes to the
dedicated team that I played by these
grants so on the 85 people we have
pretty much 20 people that are Auto
financed by these grants okay and I mean
like with 20 cigarettes enough money to
make it live okay now and we try to auto
finance this video to learning projects
as much as we can but it's also the core
for technology and really won't stay
number one on that and okay but we're
say yeah I've got one more question for
you before I open it to the audience so
the company is based in New York well
yeah why sorry why because we are we are
healthcare tech company so we should be
in SF but because we stretches too far
or we should be in Boston but it's a bit
too boring so we have been in New York
but most of our tech team is in France
France is very good for you know like
for for mathematics because we have not
a really good history of biology we only
had one double price the fully story of
better of Medicine Nobel Prize and it
was not the best one we not have we
don't put a lot of money in in biology
like the US but because we don't have
money we have like you know like tables
and can write on it and we are good in
mathematics
Ouiser so I felt like we friends worked
really good resources for machine
learning and data scientist you did not
consider coming over here to the west
coast never I mean I grew up here I grew
up in San Francisco so my parents is
amazing it's far from from Europe and
and just very far from the being two
teams here it's obviously anime and I
think like keeping talents in someone
Cisco is really hard so we didn't want
to have this pressure on tenants that's
a very important point x1 okay thank you
thank you what's open the for the
question pao-chai you go ahead can you
comment on the ownership and profit
sharing scheme it's the way we do this
today is we the way we it's a wind star
or the infrastructure the server
sometimes and and
rather than the software's with the
hospitals right we hospitals and not our
clients we are quickly free but we keep
the IP of the models that's really
something that we keep the ownership of
the models the models are adding trained
our own so much so that but then we
profit we revenue share with the
hospitals the money we make so with the
hospitals gas is revenue sharing
augmented research fabrications new
tools to be machine teachers connections
to other hospitals and we don't take the
data out and trust well okay but
literally lakhs for free so access to
shared research results that involves
data from a lot of other hospitals
without having to give up your data
exactly yeah when structure yeah on top
of that the reason there are public
databases is because we need large
enough 100,000 you know is all about
generating adequate data to be able to
run I don't know how you addressing that
issue so itself treating the requests
that are related to that that will new
device comes out with higher resolution
than one Hospital has higher resolution
data which none of the other hospital
there so what's the relevance of the how
is does your model work when there is so
much disparity between be the kind of
data that we have three related
questions about the day on the EHR unit
on essence and the data set that I put
on the servers in our in this model is
related to a specific question and is
qat data sites right so we don't really
try together oh yeah yeah so this is the
chaos are responsible curating yeah I
mean itself but this is the richness of
the people who have curated the data
sets in the servers i cuted knew about
the question and the specialist of the
wins curating is very rich it's self
carry two data sets and we can happen
of course but it's adding up in the
friendly up I mean even a minor release
is that responsive on security one data
set and and so you don't need to like
actually like go to data mining in big
EHR here they're also we have to we did
it in the past and we know how to do it
even on on regular so you know HR in
Europe and yeah on structure we don't
have epic right we have nothing and we
add billet energy that allow us to find
the right features that we need with an
LP
so we know how to do it if needed but
the best situation for us this is always
like you need to see this as a
consortium towards one question right
it's a ki consortium and sorry
so you start out before you ever use one
of those hospitals for training data you
really need to have an adequate and
automated analysis to go into the model
to start very first remaining of the
dialogue yeah so we know the answer is
first we try to be multi model so we
access to model that per patient right
because we train models on different
type of the datasets with the diagnostic
and then we deliberate underneath
energies to be able also to take you
know to be able to have cross
fertilization between the models that
really help us in small datasets but the
idea of this is having large datasets in
connecting how and if you think so I
think the point is the if that works you
can't really argue sorry the other one
is gonna be in much so we're gonna know
if it's worth of course the deprived
immunization
device it's the biggest problem of
medicine in the area right and of course
it's American with the computing new
machines that is committed by definition
today's it's still a canonization there
is four or five brands right that you
and you can do this but the future will
be that any new model of a new brand
comes it doesn't affect the prediction
and then therefore this is the power of
machine learning when the future we
really hope that any new thing won't
affect the day I and there
you don't even need to do this huge
immunization anymore if you have so many
centers that you won't have a big right
now for somebody scary right okay we've
got our next three questions you were
first then you Lin you okay Wow well so
how do i how do you end up when you go
to a doctor and you're not sure it's
gonna be accurate and you're in your
personal head points
this is mixing different hospitals in
different ways to health outcomes you
need me to get the risk can i phrase the
question of slightly let me rephrase the
question in a slightly different way
then I'm sorry the question is how do I
ensure that the doctors endpoint are the
right ones but this is a true question
for you for everything you never sure
there are ways to do error checks if you
say prostate cancer you have 10 females
in your database you know something's
wrong no we're not you know 10 years ago
you can accurately that says from
security that's yeah it's different it's
curated by yoga is curated by the best
professors in the world he doesn't know
like I mean of course like if I asked
though - are about to Tokyo Tokyo
underneath he can be wrong but problem
with trusting because the best in this
field and I don't know what is your
field but I probably know you the best
as well so we were working with the best
Cuban leaders that do curate that I said
themselves and so of course it can be a
quality check isn't it's important like
like every data set but they can be
mistakes but you need to get the risk
but we work with the consortium is built
by the best in their field so let me
rephrase the question ok normally big
data analytics is considered relatively
accurate because the size of the data
set that feeds into the AI engine is so
big that it kind of gets rid of all the
bells that the strange anomalies however
what you're doing is you're if you're
starting the training with one hospitals
data you're starting with a very small
training data set yeah and so the past
ability of the model becoming skewed
early in this iterative process that is
how a I work and you can have a lot of
validation tests so it's all about the
validation you can very easy if it
doesn't very date well you can cross the
way you do look aesthetically - and it's
completely different you can keep extra
you can keep real-world validation sets
to test your model and you can see if
there is something wrong this is very
unique so clearly and the curation of
the data upfront especially the first
data set it's very this is why we booked
me yeah yeah yeah process we found we
have to make the rodent immediately
different patches weave so our first
test is on imaging and the clinical data
sets it hasn't been included in the
dynamic no no no no no but we try to be
able to hunt enemy that so we recruited
a so it's a very important point the
most intelligence is that genes that are
the generic ones can we normalize
acquire this is the most important one
you need your meta data and need to be
to build things correctly and very well
and this is extremely important but I
think also like you know like if you
build your models imagine you be the
pyramid you want to tell it resistance
to chemotherapy for lung cancer okay the
way you can do it with with layer by
layer and you can start by you know
sensing the prediction accuracy with
just images then you can add images and
mythology mythology so medical imaging
and pathology I can see how the models
improved on that right and then you can
add the genomic in here doing training
of others layer by layer and the
multimodal way can also just not give
interpretability and different set of
biomarkers but also you can know if some
type of data in this cancer doesn't
bring in a single and and generally
doesn't mixing up everywhere I mean
genomic has been failing and crediting
anything for the last 40 years there is
one signature that is out with genomic
is called a banner print and it's good
everybody know that did amis doesn't
solve the problem of prediction so I
will not focus my attention too much on
this but this is the hardest data to
work with for sure okay your question
it's our decorative patterns it's ok
well sand the Centers and everything the
network is about this on trade networks
of all the hospitals and Cuban leaders
that are linked by our software and in
part of this ecosystem it's our research
ecosystem that we call the sorry the
other ones who curate the datasets they
note in this group and their own part of
this they all have servers and I mean
the old mentioned we have servers and
and clouds the problem that that level
is called connect so connect is there is
our product but is it gonna be launching
much you can be gonna sell it in March
but connect is the way is the federated
learning and the traceability way to
connect to this loop how to connect to
any other loop people can use related
learning to connect all their own loops
doesn't even one example rush for
example an amazing farmer is producing
genomics so dynamic also is not only
complex to to normalize ratio so complex
in terms of loss right so that producing
with a company confidential medicine
that is amazing some data a genomic data
in Germany unfortunately you cannot like
really like upload German data on the
cloud because it's probably done by
German laws so today the only solution
really to be able to to build an
intelligence on on that siloed political
silos and legal silos might be federated
learning just because generally that I
can travel is the converse computer is
the most like sensitive data I guess so
one other question can't follow up the
other product that I've seen associated
with Alcon that you didn't mention a
Socrates
so quite this is our studio yes and so
it's a it's a demo so great this is this
automation not in platform to be able to
collaborate with other scientists or
just to train your own algorithm
yourself okay so it's the platform that
allow you and I'm happy to show the demo
very similar it's kind of the whole
picture is the whole picture okay it's a
city to federated learning you can build
your model and you can ship it to other
people that we want to
okay well this is nothing I've been
talking about so this is like you
admitting in my life is a good question
it's the most important ones so really
like we you have like guidelines when
you better fit in learning models about
how people short root puree datasets all
together and then you try to build the
algorithms I will capture the different
mistakes and the different normalization
between it so we have different
algorithm of normalization we have
different algorithm also of weak
labeling which is a way just to
automatically have a label without the
annotation to see there is a difference
between your automatic labelling and the
labeling so another way to control the
quality of the labeling of your of your
images is like to be able to annotate
things and segments the images yourself
so it's it's a it's a whole process but
for sure like normalization is the
biggest challenge of this but because
it's self curity datasets and people
have it's a project every time
everything this kind of solid eyes but
hopefully in the future when you have
that's true for 2030 centers but when
you have 300 centers if one centers that
not normal I think anywhere really well
you might not affect the full stability
of the models and one model will be
stable enough when you have these
problems it won't be that much of a
problem today still is when you have
like ten farmers and and the ten farmer
has received a guideline about how you
prepare your data sets otherwise it
would be too messy right so if you are
also having a research problem as the
basis for the algorithm the algorithm
must also have some sort of a basic
sampling function to are you doing
hotter sampling wait a minute other than
being which one of the yeah we have like
we do like dozens of different close
validation we're doing fluid sensor it
equates other arctic when you take one
part of it I said you see the strategies
I've been shown before okay this is how
you cross validate and and the
capabilities are so much bigger when you
have so many like actors to play around
okay yeah thank you go ahead
so I have a question about federated
machine learning with the pharma
companies so some of the things that
where people are asking us about is what
if my data is more valuable than yours
so what if it puts you into a new
chemical space and you're just clustered
in a very small area of your data if you
can't see it at data are you also asking
for metrics around the data so it's a
very good question I think that's the
first time so we never see the data and
we hope that so if I support for the for
the middle of the project stealth Pharma
trying to predict how the molecular
binding we don't know which part of the
library is gonna put in the in the
training set so we have no idea so maybe
like like we want the training set is
being diverse as possibilities in terms
of chemicals categories but we have no
idea so we can attack the di-did you can
reinforce to the menus there is like
guidelines to enter the data sets but
there is no get lights out exactly which
which is the substance that you cannot
put into because if not you would be
cheating so yeah they are still being
like so yeah but of course like the
assisted program with revenue sharing
you wanna ruin your share
I'm molded in training ten hospitals
some people can say okay well I was the
first of me to get my mind developing so
you like the same amount of that that
isn't have the same value between yeah
you see of zero zero nine zero nine zero
ninety one it's extremely complex of
course this is all the system but I
think like it needs to be I'm kind of a
good spirit and a good collaboration and
I think trauma stands to be able to do
so so I don't even know example affinity
done in clinical trials as I'm ER
everything's failing right we're not
sharing the control arms of ours on a
trial to be able to try to understand
new value some new subgroups who is
already responder that could be in
common using any type of data so I think
nine Finnerty journey can also like go
to a lot of different spectrum and
there's of the fam'ly
to try to be able to solve this is where
as nothing I'd you know this would be
for okay go ahead in the section where
you mentioned describe my paper from
last month's in Nature Medicine so the
paper in Nature Medicine and very very
welcome to read it is can we so the
question was can we can we predict a
survival with pathology biopsies of
mesothelioma patients mesothelioma is a
where people die very quickly it was
linked to a bestows this before in a
people in the minds there is not so many
minds around but still the cancer is
increasing because we have the covered
new mutation that 21 that is actually
linked so there is a genetic
predisposition go to this cancer so we
were like it's still a problem can we
can we try to to understand if we can't
risk it predict because we always try to
predict first and then we understand
it's called reverse engineering so we
try to secondly pretty the survival of
people using pathology images so the
biopsy before the treatment can we
predict how many months and we could
actually with the pathology image is an
image predict how many months the
patient could survive quite well and we
discover actually on new subgroups of
patients with this prediction that were
living twice longer so it this is a new
samples of patients we think it should
not be three categories to categorize
nutri man it's four categories using
this predictive marker but then because
we are doctors and with physicians we
say what is the biology underlying so
then we had a technological shoulder a
pathology that can really make small
tiles very small tiles and tell you
which turns a predictive interesting to
build the model right and we discover
that the tears that were the most
interesting from the model where the
tears are welling to the stroma which is
the microbe and not of the tumor and we
could show that the microwave run seems
to be the most important thing for the
father to to be linked to the to the the
the the the survival and the prognostic
of patient which was not potencies that
had the biggest but the pathologist has
for years and we did this work in hand
with the pet the best care experts that
build the Malon with us is a kind of
with show them the trial saying what do
you think about this trial we think that
relative and what's your opinion about
the styles and they were all yet is the
stroma we know this tell them I'm not
surprised this Taza and so it was a
hand-in-hand project at the end I think
like every machine learning model is a
dialogue tool between biologists
clinicians and mathematicians is there
is no ground truth and and and this was
paper was natural medicine because we
could literally like and now we have no
into example be able to kind of localize
the T cells in the tumor just using the
genomics the beta in genomics so we can
actually like it with this multi
modality we can easily localize where
the T cells are on the tree which is a
big relative response in your therapy
marker and this is so we will try to ask
like very profound questions and now we
cannot try to link the subgroups with
genomics to understand if there is an
internal we can do targets for this myth
my things but this is really going so
you get the tradition works what's the
what's the biomarkers and imaging
biomarkers it's new before people had a
clinical biomarkers da H the sexes
people had genomics biomarkers thus in
nature that are always for Chile and
then though we have quantitative
biomarkers we have imaging biomarkers
this is completely new and for example
the stroma the soda straw is the micro
environment of the tumor it probably why
some people do response window therapy
in prostate cancer as well so now we're
trying to us also hypothesis is hand in
hand with the people that have this
question right they come up with a
question and there that nobody is feel
for 20 or 30 years and we don't and
we're gonna see with them if you can
answer something new in biology and this
is what I think it's exciting is trying
to really make some breakthrough with AI
but it always comes by being able to
predict something well and if you can so
strategically what are your visions for
beyond these two projects how do you see
the company growing do you see a need
for more people with computer science
backgrounds of any particular sort what
are the things that young people need to
know in order to kind of get involved
with federated learning well the thing
is if you do federated learning in
biology in medicine you need to be able
to build a federated learn you need to
build infrastructure so to have the
right developers the the right DevOps to
install this in hospitals that's the
first layer then you need to have the
right people that build the federated
learning algorithm for different type of
data or alter of that I connected and so
you need to have like so many different
layers to be able to do so which i think
is well so we we keep our advance and
other teams is because we have one team
provide energy went in for pathology
went in for omics and they all been
publishing and having nips price and
publishing in nature and everywhere we
have one team for federated learning we
have Wentz him for infrastructure we
have Wentz him and everybody's worked
together the biggest challenge making
all these people work together weights
or the biggest challenge once again
communication right so yeah but I think
but I I believe in the transverse or
vision of AI
these need to be very transversal
because the future cannot be that super
vertical like the AI space is developing
today no not really launching very very
vertical we gotta build regional I think
you don't get the full spectrum of the
biology with one data type and with one
center in one country so achieving that
scale is very explain
it's very expensive yeah it's very
expensive because a lot of people but I
mean I just seen the progress and the
paper we have out and we have so many
more we have 40 models of predictions of
response we have new subgroups have new
biomarkers we have new farmer working
with us I'm so proud of the ecosystem
that we will find the money and no
people I know that people are here to to
to to to to understand that it's it's
it's it's medicine for good and it's
smart AI to to understand biology it's
not like yeah so I'm certain the words
about the money will we need for that
and and also like European Europe is
putting a lot of money now I don't know
about putting a lot of money in this
collaborative efforts okay
I think that's a good note to call to
into the formal part of the session
we've got some refreshments outside I'd
really like to encourage everybody to
stay around meet each other talk about
this meet doctor close el Tomas thank
you so much